I don't think about the weather I just I
don't even iron pants the pants I'm
wearing right now it's my only pair of
pants that I we just learned how to let
us know in Australia
I pretty much is grew up surfing we've
had hail storms in Sydney but none of
this soft precious cloud like snow that
America has promised me I brought some
boots and hat do I need any more than
that it's probably wet I expected to
feel ridiculously cold sledding that's
what Santa does yes
is it like Corning's it's the movie no
he's imagining me I'm ready to see the
snow is the snow ready for me come on
that is dark look at that hey he's
actually like Christmas geez what are
they pine trees
it's like cuddly oh my god I can't see
beyond this it's like Universal Studio
is currently on but it's real
wait is that a house wait do people
actually live up here oh this is school
why we've seen snow ski bunnies don't
slip oh my gosh snow it's like hot
potato but it's cold potato elion
literally melts under your fingers all
right I'm really cold where's my
polkadot sweater it's just like water I
got so many layers on the carpet
it's stuck in my genes I'll help you put
this on
good there's no way that every one of
these is different I mean it all looks
the same
ball Bank so I didn't think I've ever
been this cold ever high school to see
and i've definitely never won this many
clothes all at once I mean it looks like
snow but the minute it hits the ground
it got it disappears I feel like I
expected it to feel kind of like sand
but it's just like you just walk through
and it's just like sugar all right hold
it hold it
and I will I will submit around us
submit around it maybe it's just wearing
like a princess dress oh my god well how
do we stop there you go first
again forget mud wrestling snow
wrestling yes a prototype for it cheap
ceiling digger they're gonna be like -
ah see guys and snow ah yeah
but I thought we could like hold the
snow without it kind of just like
melting in okay though this is nothing
now like you touch down it was it just
vanished
I can't feel my feet I come back if it
was more I like the idea of snow
surrounding a hot tub you like get
around the pair of like boy shots in the
snow how do you do
hey Russ go check it out I found some of
that yellow snow
check out that's like a yellow snow
looks like it says SV